I never got into diets though I did take
diet pills in the 70s
I love these pills they give me so much
energy and I can eat whatever I want
Oh Bob Scully why are you always telling
us about your disgusting body I don't
see anything that's because it's all
bored
[Applause]
how are you married
try better we have no idea what this is
I think it's our cookies no it's a pizza
it's just a cookie pizza another case
old no detectives we owe them dough what
the hell are you guys doing out here
finally eating breakfast we snuck the
microwave out here so that we could cook
our burritos like real policemen now
they have to use the toaster oven
enjoy your 16 minute cook times idiots
guys this is amazing
back off it's our microwave hours hey
nobody wants your microwave can I just
give my case to Hitchcock and Scully and
they clearly have a ton of time on their
hands
Hitchcock hasn't even gotten out of his
chair today PJ I can go anywhere in this
thing but shouldn't
so if we're gonna start a secret office
on the roof we need equipment that means
chairs desks printers pens but we got to
sneak it out so we need a distraction
okay here's what I'm thinking we give
that dog a bunch of chocolates it dies
well everyone's celebrating okay Amy's
too close to this Rosa
got any ideas you've got things Scully
just set fire to the kitchen sink
perfect let's use that Wow
the chairs look amazing can't believe
you two aren't my biggest problem today
or not who is so guy got stabbed at
third Union you know what that means I
got third street bagels yeah
it's so nice and surprising when
somebody thinks of others yeah Scully I
was thinking W I was thinking about how
stupid your face is that's it I'm
licking all these bagels you get nothing
who do you think yours fits gonna stop
me brother you don't know me at all mmm
Oh what are we watching they've been
fighting like little kids all morning
and I can't get him to stop I've tried
everything
ordering them to stop well that's really
all I tried but I'm disappear your
opposite that shouldn't work guys why
are you fighting your best friends every
Sunday after church Scully and I have
dinner together at wing [ __ ] we know you
get ribs and white Russians and watch
Undercover Boss last night Scully said
he was sick so I went by myself guess
who was there healthy as a clam mr. liar
and his new tart Cyndi Schatz what
happened to our bro code
badge before heads John no sorry but
it's five against two wait you assumed
Hitchcock and I want to eat that Turkey
yeah thank you thanks for taking us to
lunch Jake
of course yeah whatever you want oh man
I already ate I guess I'll just have a
cheeseburger deluxe couples license
apply maybe an egg cream okay Anna
waffle so look a big important drug case
came across my desk and I need your help
only problem is Sarge doesn't think you
can handle it he's right no he's not
look you're Hitchcock and Scully you
guys are legends you single-handedly
caught the Prospect Park flasher well he
was being chased by other cops but he
did slip on my spilled chili and who
bumped into Scully cause in this bill me
damn right and who fell asleep under
their desks and caught the janitor
stealing evidence
did and who sued the department and got
triple-ply toilet paper in every
precinct we did Terry thinks you guys
are too old and too lazy to handle this
but I know what you're really made up
you're gonna take this case and prove
them wrong
yeah we're still gonna use lunch right
oh dear God sorry we're late
turns out the front doors a push not a
pull you always get mad when I spent
time with Cindy so I lied because I
didn't want you to throw a fit you cook
you're the cook snowflake no you are
oh geez I have no idea what's going on
you got stopped for being black kid woke
Scully he's here okay he's here
everybody be cool why do you got your
shirt off can't spill food on your shirt
or not wearing one
what Scully [ __ ] she's gonna live
forever how did you secure hangovers oh
I didn't drink I was however extremely
into cocaine for most of 1986 I gotta
tell you the truth Hitchcock Katie the
truth you and me man we're gonna be
co-captains but first up taking you to
Japan I'm already packed
I had three heart attacks that you're in
declared bankruptcy Japan move it over
Bali Hey what Scully what's going on was
it that update on the project Peralta is
under arrest for possession of a
controlled substance on pills in his
apartment
Jake I know what he's talking about I
swear I don't know how those pills got
in my apartment wait Jake Scully
tell them we're cops tell them new
something events new some limits
ught that means tournament I said we
were terms I got it don't worry we are
turnips dope that was English
my first question is why are the two of
you doing this self-evaluation together
Scully doesn't handle pressure well not
to brag but Scully and I have a combined
total of 14 arrests would have been 20
but well I got 14 that's not enough
arrest well no one asked you
it's a self-evaluation AJ see the place
on the corner of serving lemonade and
heat to keep the jar it's pretty cool
yes that's very cool Scully
mmm will you excuse me just one moment
oh sure guys guys guys
Scully has a mason jar full of lemonade
you called us in here to tell us that no
I called you in here to change your
lives for you see a mere five minutes
ago Hitchcock introduced me to his new
goldfish who lives in Oh identical mason
jar oh this isn't gonna end well there
are two possible outcomes and we're
gonna bet on which one happens first so
well Hitchcock put fish food in Scully's
lemonade or will Skelly drink
Hitchcock's goldfish now you would think
that putting fish food into lemonade hey
dr. strike is on fish what
hey if you need more fax machines
there's a ton of them in that storage
room where I go to take a nap what why
did you say something and I'm once again
its gawk and Scully save the day you
didn't do anything it was all skully
we're a package deal everyone knows that
okay
what's going on with those files oh
we're not working on them
we're on strike hunger strike you're
eating potato chips chips don't count my
doctor said they have Zero nutritional
value we want meatball subs you had no
right to take ours have a nice weekend
Peralta yeah nothing special
gotta come you missed Scully's birthday
there's kind of a big one nobody showed
at the party guys guys guys
we missed Scully's birthday and it was a
big one I know I panicked and said I had
to go to the vet because my puppy cat
got sick I said I had to take my mom to
get birth control pills that's better
than my excuse I said I had to go to our
girls bat mitzvahs squad we missed
Scully's birthday and it was a big one I
told them I was in Ecuador I think they
bought it we gotta make it up to him
let's give him cash everyone put in $20
each ah yes
I'll cover you it's going Oh we're sorry
that we missed your party well I don't
worry about it all that stuff to do
yes the capital of Ecuador is Quito Oh
anyway happy birthday from all of us
thank you you're the best I can't
believe it the fake birthday work you're
a genius
we're bougie deuces tub jack about that
was right thumbtack look artists Kelly
how was your weekend looks fun
Kelly and I hit the park went for a long
walk fell asleep watching TV wow sounds
like a fun weekend with Kelly
so Kelly is that Scully's wife or his
dog wait Noah no Scully's wife's name I
think Kelly's his dog went for a long
walk that's what you do with a dog you
can go on a long walk with a person at
sunset talking about nothing and
everything sounds awful hit the park
that's a dog my wife takes the babies to
the park all the time all right we're
doing this
let's play why for doc hey so Scully
what do you do at the park with Kelly oh
we just walk around she gets antsy if
she doesn't get outside enough and then
it's just yeah yeah yeah all day long
hey what's Kelly's favorite food peanut
butter she'll eat it right out of the
jar
how old is coming again well she's
getting up there but if she's free spry
for age especially considering she got
hit by that car a year ago oh that's so
awful was she chasing something into the
street or yeah just getting me the
newspaper all right this is useless
Scully is Kelly your wife or your dog
how can you ask me that I still don't
know which it is could be either I could
not tell you hey jakey
yeah I'd love to chip it at Kent
Hitchcock and I are eating cake for
dinner and watching the movie I asked
Amy if she wants to come over I'm
hanging up so what'd I miss
tell me all the jokes everything funny
that happened Charles you really need to
get back to this guy called himself
Scully by accident
I did but it brought me and Scully
closer together drinks are on me okay
where's Scully Oh No
you